- This is very good but I might
not like what this tastes,
but I'll eat it, that's
different that it choking me
and me dying.
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just want to be happy
don't you wanna be happy?
(intense music)
♪ I go oh so fuckin' crazy all the time, ♪
♪ Talkin' yoko ono loko
got a lady on my mind. ♪
♪ And they got me in a choke-hold as ♪
♪ I try to walk the line. ♪
♪ So I went and shot my ego
just to watch that fucker die. ♪
♪ Oh my oh my now, rockin'
rollin' with the tides ♪
♪ Not tied down, come along. ♪
- [Gary] We spent $6 million for this ad.
We're gonna stop this ad
and waste $4.3 million.
Actually we're gonna
waste $8.6 million because
we're gonna waste $4.3 million
right now in this commercial.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Hi nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Hello, how are you?
- I'm nice.
- [Gary] Hello.
- Hello.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Mike.
- [Gary] Hello.
I believe in passion and
optimism and pushing yourself
but I disproportionately
believe in practicality,
patience and hard work too,
and that they seem to be
at odds with each other.
(applause)
- Many of us have to do
things that we don't actually
like or love but deep
inside we have something
that we really want to do
but we cannot do because
of the responsibilities and
you know we have to have
a stable income, we have
to do something because
we have to but don't love.
The question is, what
are the three activities
the three main goals that you have to set
in order to move a step closer towards
doing something that you actually love?
- [Gary] So it's a really
interesting question
and I was listening and I hope
people are paying attention
most people spend money on dumb things
which then forces them to
do things they don't want.
So step number one for most people in here
they should sell their home,
take the money and go rent.
They should return their
BMW and get a Toyota.
(speaking off mic)
And that's why, and honestly that becomes
the vulnerability, why do you want to BMW?
- Because I love the
car, because it ran good.
I love driving it, so I don't know.
- [Gary] So to me that's where
it gets interesting right?
Do you or do you like what the brand does
to make you look to other people?
I don't know I'm not
assuming I don't know.
I know I have a point, I don't know you
but I know in the macro that 98% of people
that buy a Mercedes or
BMW likes what it makes
other people think of
them not that they like it
and that $487 a month versus
what they really need,
which is $100 a month is why
they have a job they hate
because they're paying for
a life that means nothing.
(applause)
Guys, the amount of people
in here that have a job
they hate and they buy
things they don't care about
to impress people they
don't give a fuck about
scares the shit out of me.
(soothing music)
You are asking only 'cause you
wanna have a bigger market.
- Yeah I wanna have a
bigger market actually.
- Well guess what, Polish
is not a very big language.
- Yeah, I know.
- Okay.
- Exactly.
- So yes, the answer is
yes, you have this one.
- Okay, you guys were awesome.
Thank you very much.
- Good (laughs).
You're welcome.
- That's yours?
- [Man] Yes.
- Does anybody want some wine?
(laughter)
No really does anybody want?
You know, I think I might-
- [Man] Talking with
you is better than wine.
(laughter)
- [Woman] I am a very
young mother too so that's-
- Lemme tell you a couple things.
- [Woman] What how to do-
- How to prioritize, how to pick
a to do.
- No no no.
- How to do everything?
- You think I, yes!
Exactly, on time (laughs).
- The first thing you have
to do is pay attention
to anything that you're
doing that is taking time,
like watching TV or reading-
- [Woman] I now have to read?
- Good.
(laughter)
Whether looking on the
Instagram, you have to look at
every hour.
[Woman] Are you doing
those posts like your own?
- Yes.
- [Woman] Every.
Oh my God.
- Of course.
I'm running a 900
- [Woman] Can you do
something else?
- person company that
has four global offices.
I have, I produced content every day.
I post I reply, I do this in...
What you'll learn, look, but
I didn't do all those things
when I was 30, like
you have to be patient.
And the mother thing you have to focus on.
The singing and marketing,
you try to balance them.
Thank you so much.
- [Daniel] Hi, Daniel, Italian publisher.
- Oh that's amazing to
meet you, how are you?
- Fine, fine.
- I think we need to family photo.
(speaks in foreign language)
(camera clicks)
- I trust you 100%.
- Thank you so much.
- That's why I didn't
even want to talk about
it when I got here, nothing
to talk about.
- I know.
- [Gary] Yes, how are you?
- Hello.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
I'm always sayin', it's one
thing that I don't like it
versus I can't breathe.
- Yeah.
- Those are two very different things.
This is very good but I might not like
what this tastes but I'll eat it.
That's different than it
choking me and me dying.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you have to ask yourself,
staying in the family business,
is that killing you?
Then you gotta go and
become a guitar player,
or social media or whatever.
But, if you have that
big of an opportunity,
you may want to eat more
shit for 5 more years.
I ate shit building wealth for my family,
not even for me, and then still
at 35 had more than enough
time in a very short period
of time, here I am at four...
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- At 27 you're impatient, that's it.
Because I promise you one thing,
you go and do what you love
and it fails and all that
real estate, all your other
friends who did it make a lot of money,
you're gonna be at 33 very upset.
- Yeah.
- Understand?
- Fun.
- [Man] Okay, I love you so much man.
- I love you back.
♪ They try to tell me positivity is key ♪
♪ And there ain't no stoppin' me. ♪
♪ Nah, they'd stop me very easy ♪
♪ That's why my attitude is very yeezy. ♪
♪ All I do will never please me ♪
♪ Man, these options got me indecisive ♪
♪ Coincidences, I'm romanticizing. ♪
♪ Keats or Byron ♪
♪ Emerson or Thoreau ♪
♪ Transcending now here we go ♪
♪ Chemicals in my throat ♪
♪ Ripping joints ♪
♪ Building to the tipping point ♪
♪ Different points of view ♪
♪ Got the boy confused ♪
♪ Don't know what to do ♪
♪ Man, you read the news? ♪
♪ No wonder why these
kids out drinking booze ♪
♪ M1, Sass, Ketamine ♪
♪ In search of the better things ♪
♪ But skip the fine
print on the lettering ♪
♪ God called I just let it ring. ♪
(intense music)